ora pão especial pesa mais o vídeo e
hoje vou ensinar como fazer um super
avião de papel que se destaca pelo
alcance e altura do vôo e é produto com
vocês podem parar agora mesmo velhos
então vamos lá isso só primeiro vamos
dar uma folha a4 com impressora
mas se vocês não tiverem uma folha a4
podem usar outro folha qualquer um
portanto é que tenho mais ou menos essas
dimensões e montanha que os furos
laterais com as folhas de cadernos têm
habitualmente até porque vocês fizerem
como folha confúcio atrás voz avião vai
entender por um dos lados vai ficar no
partido mas leva à outra
então vamos lá primeiro mundo pra folha
sim ao bairro
o desemprego e esta parte estudar para
esta linha centro
vamos fazer isto mais uma vez presta
linha
o sapato aquino de dólar estar assim eu
esperar a folha nos ajudar 90 graus e
vamos dobrar o avaí nesta quarta para
ficar tudo é resistente que mais encanta
com mais volume tem tendência a fugir
para um dos lados
então faça um pequeno lago tem do outro
pois é só juntar abrir mão de obra isso
vamos fazer dois triângulos retângulos
na avenida docente
se vocês tiverem dificuldade em
visualizar essa linha aqui que eu ter um
crime uma vez que fui a branca
vocês podem contar sempre de me dar
prazer pra quem está mesmo no centro
agora só vim cá eu mesmo pra esse lado
com mel
o avião tem que ficar simétricos não
seja simétrico não houve aula
pronto agora quando convém ficar melhor
estas linhas aqui cobrar cobrar esta
parte que também é e pronta que é a
linha do centro até passar da linha do
centro e vou ter que passar por este
lado aí então grimm podem porque os
dedos pastar já está agora fazer o mesmo
pressionado empurra passar da linha do
maio deveria passar para o outro lado
tudo ficará bem estar para aqui vamos
empurrar o grêmio pra frente
um texto lindo aqui de uma mini
triângulo conhecida com esta linha aqui
fazendo isso vamos obter um pequeno
triângulo que vamos dobrar aqui por
baixo estava levando a cabo o triângulo
fazer uma obra tão perto ainda te
assaltar assim e verificar se está tudo
alinhavado estiver pronto pode brincar
com 10 e voltar aqui estavam lá ficava
temos aqui esta linha e vamos dobrar se
agora vamos dar a amplitude das asas até
aqui um ponto de referência está aqui
também a cair 1 da equipe neste domingo
aqui referência porque esse ponto tem
que tocar nesta parte da folha
podemos jogar que concluir todas as 53
pronto consegue que vocês façam o
seguinte foi aqui no ponto e não ponham
estudei como na linha do centro oeste
uma pequena distância de uma rua que o
dedo a mesma linha do maio e deixa aqui
maioria para o lado enquanto o be fica
minha mãe quase quase a ser feito isso
vim cá aí claro que convém que esta
partida seja aqui para dentro não seja
aqui pra fora de posição vai ganhar
agora país ficar igualzinho do outro
lado tem que ficar mesmo igualzinho não
vai cair para um dos lados assim vamos
dobrada
agora sobre o por uma asa em cima da
outra
joaquim joão jardim vai agora prosseguir
por um mazda em cima da outra com muito
cuidado está a cumprir colocar pra
dentro vai ter que ficar aqui dentro não
vai prender aqueles idosos que deixar
isso aqui por enquanto eu vou fazer é
cauda tocar outra folha é em vão por
dois dedos 15 pele dos dedos
marcão estava por três pôs mais dos
dentes seja quatro vezes ao total
marco cunha pois tal bronze
agora vamos ter rasgado está tratando
aqui se vocês quiserem podem usar o
tesouro
eu vou jogar desta vez não estou velha
senhora vai pegar
talvez esse banho de bola
é pra subir citá lo agora ficou muito
bravo é igual à mãe
inicialmente eu fiz este avião mas sem a
cauda aí pois quando fui fazer um teste
que acontecerá que eu queria assim a
cabeça é tão fácil porque a cauda ele
vai estabilizar e vai pronto quando
acaba a energia potencial quando faz o
lançamento
eu fico a plenário até o chão como não
tinha muito peso aqui caí assim pra
baixo foi o de ensinar a cauda não ficou
sujeito mesmo
agora vou abrir e voltou pra aqui da
linha do centro
algumas pessoas perguntam como é que os
aviões basicamente eu faço vários judeus
é e vou poupar que vou testando deus
pois faço apenas ajustou pico projeto
pronto caiu assim o peso traz para os
equilibrar e panorâmico por uma causa
nessas situações não funcionar
o texto avião é dos melhores que já fiz
mesmo dizer não sei se é mesmo melhor
porque este vulcão espetáculo até era
dobrar aqui a mãe chega de promoção
avião já viram no início talvez estas
partes que ficam por dentro você fica
mais resistente
agora um por aqui três dedos segurar um
é que
futebolsc com a unha pronto é só
promover confusão 3 de desconto é mais
ou menos uns três dedos são o pai 25 de
maio ky os meus três deles são 25 de
maio
vamos fazer assim o brasil tem provado
agora eu vou continuar aqui o avião
pronto agora por dois dias aqui traz a
volta de quase 25 20
marco cunha e vim como que vem para
frente vai ficar só com um dedo e 100
não usar você não chega a 90 centímetros
mais ou menos um cêntimo é prático e
agora vão fazer tanto imaginar que uma
linha que vai daqui até que a linha
eu já estava aqui a linha de um lado ao
outro
agora vou virar por outro lado fazer o
mesmo
parece que o avião já está aprovado mas
náo a parte mais importante fazer agora
é o seguinte acontece vocês pensarem sim
houve um vai brincar e isso vai estragar
o percentual alcance tempo vou eu vai
voar enquanto vocês lançaram enquanto
vocês pronto quando o avião poderá que
ela força inicial que vocês deram um
avião que vai vai atender a fazer isto e
vai de controlar se cair
agora se nós conseguimos juntar as asas
não vai conseguir plenário quando acabar
aquela energia inicial com nossos
estamos a ouvir ela cai então vamos
juntar agora essas como fazemos isto que
o viam estou vendo este pequeno acaba
daqui até aqui e pediram mais e fazer
uma marca no mais o ambiente
feito isto vamos fazer um triângulo
assim cai nesta marca e nesta parte aqui
em casa vai estar também complicada
agora irá por outro lado em casa para
este lado
agora muita atenção que só a cair
enquanto na cabuçu no triângulo sejam
porque vosso tendo agora vão abrir este
segurando os nossos dedos na minha cara
vou ver isso aqui no méxico só esta
parte aqui do triângulo
não vejo todos fazendo pecado não
costuma dar problema quando faço esse
tipo de coisas pequeninas plantão
empurrar agora vai dobrar aqui do lado
os encarar assim respectivas de frente e
agora vamos empurrar está 100 para trás
e agora vamos pôr como estava
inicialmente mostrar agora com o mesmo
prestar contas aqui um biquíni de frente
é mais resistente permite que se junte e
não aconteceu ele sabe que ele e agora
pra finalizar essa por cauda é mais uma
coisa pronto vocês vocês julgarem o
vosso avião porque estamos dependendo do
peso da folha que todas as folhas também
são bastante diferentes umas das outras
vocês vão lançar isso vossa avião
começar a cair para baixo assim que
vocês vêem mas a gente tiver com a
tendência que sempre abaixo vocês função
geralmente a causa por trás até que eu
cycle bruno aguiar foi pessoal eu
desperto deputado e se você digitar o
mesmo da jiva sozinha o rosto bonito e
se inscreva no canal e que estuda ajudar
na divulgação e evolução do meu trabalho
e claro que tiverem sugestões de
projetos deixem nos comentários
a eni é explodir o soffin obrigado e até
a próxima tal